The safety and quality of the final
juice sold to the consumer ultimately
depends on the safety and quality of the
raw material. The raw materials include
the fruit and or vegetable, water, and
any additives used at any point in the
process. In addition, the environment in
and around the growing fields and the
packing house can affect the safety and
quality of the raw material. Microbial
contamination of produce can occur at
any point. One of the keys to reducing
microbial risks on the farm is the
commitment of the farmer and all farm
workers. The raw materials used to make
fruit and vegetable juices are grown and
produced in many different geographical
areas. Examples range from oranges grown
in Florida to apples from Washington to
carrots grown in California to
cranberries from the bogs of
Massachusetts.
In addition to materials grown in the
United States, raw material is produced
in many countries throughout the world.
This material comes in all shapes and
sizes. The processor may receive this
material as whole fruits and vegetables,
purees, or single strength juices and
juice concentrates. Containers used to
ship this material can be as varied as a
small wood basket to a very large
stainless steel tank. No matter what the
source of the raw material or the manner
in which it arrives at the processing
plant, the processor should be concerned
with the controls used to minimize the
potential contamination of the juice
components at all stages of growth,
storage, processing, and transportation.
Resources available to food companies
and growers include the guide to
minimize microbial food safety hazards
for fresh fruits and vegetables,
published in October 1998 by the Food
and Drug Administration and Food
Production and Environmental
Stewardship: Examples of How Food
Companies Work with Growers, published
by the Environmental Protection Agency.
These documents provide examples of how
a processor can interact with a grower
to ensure the safety of the raw material
and may be used to construct grower
agreements, which could include water
quality issues, chemicals used,
commodity or variety grown, minimum
grades or standards, and other areas as
deemed appropriate. Growers should be
aware of the microbiological problems
that can occur and need to take steps to
help protect the public health. There's
no way to guarantee that everything
grown on the farm is free from harmful
microorganisms.
But by taking some preventive measures
during all phases of production, these
risks can be reduced. In this module, we
will be discussing the basic principles
and recommended good agricultural and
manufacturing practices for field and
packing house operators to minimize
microbial food safety hazards in the
production, packing, and transportation
of fresh fruits and vegetables.
Analyzing the risk of microbial
contamination includes several major
areas of concern. soil, water quality
and cooling, field packing facility
sanitation and transportation, worker
hygiene and pest control. Each operator
should decide which combination of
proper agricultural and manufacturing
practices are most appropriate for them.
By identifying basic principles of
microbial food safety within the
processes of growing, harvesting,
packing, and transporting fresh produce,
you will be better prepared to recognize
and address the principal elements known
to cause concern to microbial food
safety. These include principle one,
prevention of microbial contamination of
fresh produce is favored over reliance
on corrective actions once contamination
has occurred. Principle two, to minimize
microbial food safety hazards in fresh
produce, growers, packers or shippers
should use good agricultural and
manufacturing practices in those areas
over which they have control. Principle
three, fresh produce can become
microbiologically contaminated at any
point along the farm-totable food chain.
The major source of microbial
contamination with fresh produce is
associated with human or animal feces.
Principle four, whenever water comes in
contact with produce, its source and
quality dictates the potential for
contamination.
Minimize the potential of microbial
contamination from water used with fresh
fruits and vegetables.
Principle five, practices using animal
manure or municipal bioolid wastes
should be managed closely to minimize
the potential for microbial
contamination of fresh produce.
Principle six, worker hygiene and
sanitation practices during production,
harvesting, sorting, packing, and
transport play a critical role in
minimizing the potential for microbial
contamination of fresh produce.
Principle seven, follow all applicable
local, state, and federal laws and
regulations or corresponding or similar
laws, regulations, or standards for
operators outside the US for
agricultural practices.
Principle eight, accountability at all
levels of the agricultural environment,
including the farm, packing facility,
distribution center, and transport
operation is important to a successful
food safety program. There should be
qualified personnel and effective
monitoring to ensure that all elements
of the program function correctly and to
help track produce back through the
distribution channels to the producer.
There are many possible ways for produce
to become contaminated by harmful
microorganisms during production,
harvest, and handling. These may include
soil, irrigation water, animal manure,
inadequately composted manure, wild and
domestic animals, inadequate worker
hygiene, harvesting equipment, transport
containers, field to packing facility,
wash and rinse water, unsanitary
handling during sorting, equipment used
to soak, pack or cut produce, ice,
cooling units, transport vehicles,
improper storage conditions, and
crosscontamination.
Biological hazards can stem from the use
of manure as a fertilizer, improper
storage of manure, agricultural
chemicals, animal waste, and unclean
irrigation water. Fertilizing with
manure can cause cases of foodborne
illness. If manure is used for
fertilization and soil building, only
well composted manure should be used.
Also, the time between the application
of manure to production areas and the
harvesting of crops should be maximized.
Raw or inadequately treated manure
should not be applied to a vegetable
crop during the growing season. While
manure is stored or treated, it is
important to prevent contamination of
fields or water caused by runoff or
windblown particles from the manure.
It's also important to keep the manure
area far from vegetable fields and
packing houses.
To minimize exposure to animal waste,
livestock should not be allowed to roam
near the production fields. Growers
should determine whether surrounding
fields and farms are used for animal
production. Growers should ensure that
animal waste from adjacent fields or
waste storage facilities does not
contaminate the produce production areas
during heavy rains, especially if fresh
produce is grown in low-lying fields or
orchards. Measures might include
physical barriers such as ditches,
mounds, grass saw waterways, diversion
berms, and vegetable buffer areas. In
addition, high concentrations of
wildlife such as deer or water foul in a
field may increase the potential for
microbial contamination.
Control of wild animal populations in
the field may be difficult, especially
where crop production areas are adjacent
to wooded areas, open meadows, and
waterways. Federal, state, or local
animal protection requirements should
also be considered. However, to the
extent possible where high
concentrations of wildlife are a
concern, growers should consider
establishing good agricultural practices
to deter or redirect wildlife to areas
with crops that are not destined for the
fresh produce market.
Agricultural production chemicals should
only be used according to the label,
which includes the application rate,
re-entry date, and safe harvest date.
The prescribed use of these chemicals
will prevent any pesticide or chemical
residues that pose a chemical hazard.
Water used in crop production involves
numerous field operations, including
irrigation, applications of pesticides,
growth regulators, and fertilizers, and
frost control. Post-th harvest uses
include produce rinsing, cooling,
washing, waxing, and transport. Water
can also be a carrier of many
microorganisms.
Wherever water comes into contact with
fresh produce, its quality dictates the
potential for pathogen contamination.
The quality of water, how and when it is
used, and the characteristics of the
crop influence the potential for water
to contaminate produce. In general, the
quality of water in direct contact with
the edible portion of produce may need
to be of better quality compared to uses
where there is minimal contact. Other
factors that influence the potential for
contact with waterbornne pathogens and
their likelihood of causing foodborne
illness include the condition and type
of crop, the amount of time between
contact and harvest, and posth harvest
handling practices. Produce that has a
large surface area, such as leafy
vegetables, and that with topographical
features such as rough surfaces that
foster attachment or enttrapment, may be
at greater risk from pathogens if they
are present, especially if contact
occurs close to harvest or during post-h
harvest handling.
Testing agricultural water for the
presence of indicator organisms such as
total colifforms or fecal cholifforms
allows a grower to build a history and
knowledge of the quality of their water.
It may also provide a grower with
information to use when planning and
implementing a corrective action plan
should high levels of indicator
organisms occur. The best quality water
should be used for crop protection
sprays and other water uses that contact
the edible portion of the crop,
especially close to harvest.
Water quality is even more important
when water contacts produce after
harvest, such as for cooling or washing
operations. Water should be safe and
sanitary for its intended use, both at
the start of and throughout all
processes. Not only is highquality water
important for safety reasons, but it
also increases the posth harvest quality
of produce by decreasing spoilage.
Various methods are available for
cooling produce, including water, ice,
and forced air. The method used depends
on the fruit or vegetable and the
resources of the operator. In most
instances, cooling with air such as
vacuum coolers or fans will pose the
lowest risk. Water and ice used in
cooling operations should be considered
a potential source of pathogenic
contamination. Further, reuse or
recycling of water to cool continuous
loads of produce increases the risk of
crosscontamination.
Contaminated produce from a single
container going through a cooling
process may result in the buildup of
pathogens in the cooling water supply.
Operators should follow good
manufacturing practices to ensure that
chilling does not introduce food safety
hazards. Practices may include the
following. Maintain temperatures that
promote optimum produce quality.
Maintain air cooling equipment and
cooling areas. Air cooling equipment and
cooling areas should be periodically
cleaned and inspected. Potential sources
of contamination should not be located
near air intakes. Consider the use of
antimicrobial chemicals in cooling water
when appropriate.
Keep water and ice clean and sanitary.
Consider periodic microbial testing of
chilling water and water used to make
ice. Operators should contact ice
suppliers for information about the
source and quality of their ice. Water
in hydrocoolers should be changed as
often as needed. manufacture, transport,
and store ice under sanitary conditions.
Chilling equipment such as hydrocoolers
and containers holding produce during
chilling operations should be clean and
sanitary. Field soil should be removed
as much as possible from produce and
containers prior to chilling. Interiors
of hydrocoolers should routinely be
cleaned and sanitized. If antimicrobials
such as chlorine or ozone are used to
maintain water quality, their
concentration and any other factors such
as pH and temperature that impact the
effectiveness of the antimicrobial
should be actively monitored and
managed.
Microbial contamination or
crosscontamination of fresh produce
during preh harvest and harvest
activities may result from contact with
soils, fertilizers, water, workers, and
harvesting equipment such as harvesting
machinery, knives, containers, tables,
baskets, packaging materials, brushes,
and buckets. Any of these may be a
source of pathogenic microorganisms.
Growers should consider the following.
Facilities used to store fresh produce
should be cleaned and as necessary
disinfected prior to harvest. These
facilities should also be inspected for
evidence of pests such as rodents,
birds, and insects. Discard damaged
containers that are no longer cleanable
in an effort to reduce possible
microbial contamination of fresh
produce. Clean containers or bins before
using to transport fresh produce. Ensure
that produce that is washed, cooled or
packaged in the field is not
contaminated in the process. Contact
with manure or bioolids, poor quality
water, workers with poor hygiene and
unclean packaging or packing boxes
greatly increases the risk of microbial
contamination.
Remove as much dirt and mud as possible
from the produce before it leaves the
field.
Operations with poor sanitation in the
packing environment can also
significantly increase the risk of
contaminating fresh produce. Pathogenic
microorganisms may be found on the
floors and in the drains in the packing
facility and on the surfaces of sorting,
grading, and packing equipment. Without
good sanitary practices, any of these
surfaces that come in contact with fresh
produce could be a potential source of
microbial contamination.
The design, construction, use, and
general cleanliness of the facility and
equipment can help reduce the risk of
crosscontamination of produce.
The proper transport of fresh produce
helps reduce the potential for microbial
contamination.
Microbial crosscontamination from other
foods and non-food sources and
contaminated surfaces may occur during
loading, unloading, storage, and
transportation operations. Wherever
produce is transported and handled, the
sanitation conditions should be
evaluated.
As previously mentioned, many pathogens
can be transferred to fresh fruit and
vegetables by ill workers who pick,
package, or handle the produce. Common
sense and training can reduce
contamination from humans. Frequent
proper handwashing is the most important
strategy to prevent food bornne illness
outbreaks. The importance of food
workers understanding and practicing
proper hygiene cannot be overemphasized
and are discussed in module three. Many
insect pests can be controlled through
integrated pest management, IPM, which
combines biological control with
chemical control. Multiple controls may
be integrated for maximum effect.
Insects by themselves can cause a great
deal of damage to any commodity if left
uncontrolled. In addition, secondary
damage to the commodity caused by
associated organisms can be of great
concern. One of the primary pests for
apples is the coddling moth. The larvae
burrows into the flesh, leaving an open
wound on the fruit. This wound can then
be infected with bacteria, molds, and
fungi.
Patchulin, a toxic product of mold
growth, can then be formed in the wound.
Patchulin is heat stable and will not be
removed or inactivated by intervention
techniques applied to the final juice.
Reducing or eliminating the amount of
insect damage to the apple in the field
will reduce or eliminate the amount of
patchulin found in the final juice.
Therefore, appropriate levels of insect
control on the farm can help ensure a
safe and consumable product. Pests can
also be a source of and a means for
spreading microbial pathogens in the
field and packing facility. Pest control
management is discussed in detail in
module 4.
The ability to identify the source of a
product can serve as an important
complement to good agricultural and
manufacturing practices intended to
minimize liability and prevent the
occurrence of food safety problems. The
source of all raw materials should be
well documented in case a trace back is
needed. In addition, documentation on
any water or additive testing,
certificates of analysis, minimum grades
and/or standards met, lot
identification, date received or
shipped, agreements, and processing
documentation will help investigators in
the event of a problem and may limit
your liability. Documentation of date of
harvest, farm identification, and who
handled the product from grower to
receiver should be part of the shipping
manifest. Information that needs to be a
part of the manifest can be specified in
the agreement between the supplier and
the processor. Trace back is further
discussed in module six.